Because Charlie Kirk is young and he was
growing and he was learning. He didn't
know everything.
In his early years, he was very zealous.
He was pro-Israel all the like I was
because of bad theology. But as he was
maturing and due to the influence of his
Catholic wife, he was awakening to the
fact that maybe he's wrong and he was
trying starting to change his position.
But it was too late for him because he
already invested so much time in being
pro- Israel, pro-Zionist as a Christian.
So then he got the backing of Jewish
billionaires who are pro-Israel and his
hands were tied.
Yep. Exactly. I'm going to bring the
receipts. Mithra
here. Let me play one clip from Candace
Owens. And by the way, Candace Owens has
documented
that Charlie Kirk, her and Charlie were
best of friends and they would talk to
each other. Charlie Kirk was praying the
rosary. Did you know that
Charlie Kirk was regularly going to mass
and then she told Charlie Kirk, "You're
too smart to remain a Protestant. When
are you going to become Catholic?"
Do you know that Charlie Kirk was
changing due to the influence of his
wife,
a devout Catholic who was winning him
with her prayers and her love and her
piety. Let me play just one segment from
Candace Owens today.
I'll be playing more this upcoming week.
Lord willing, not tonight.
Yes, I have a picture of him. He was in
mass with his holding his child in his
arms. But here you go. Candace Owens.
She She brings the receipts and I'm not
here to be political. Why? Because
number one, I'm not a politician.
Number two, I'm not that educated about
the political ideologies. My forte by
the grace of God is theology, exesus,
early church teachings on core essential
doctrines of the faith. Islam, trinity.
I am a neopight when it comes to
politics. But I'm forced now to pay
attention because of what's taking
place. And remember what I said, do not
throw out the baby with the bathwater.
Chew the meat, spit out the bones,
separate the wheat from the chaff.
I am now starting, believe it or not, to
appreciate Nick Fuentes more and more. I
swear, I'm starting to appreciate him.
I'm starting to like him more. He's a
little too much for my own. And I'm a
guy. I'll cuss you out. But Nick Fuentes
makes some excellent points.
All right. His expertise is on the
political ideologies.
I hope God sanctifies him and me and the
Lord transforms him and me and forgive
us and save us so we can finish the
race. So he's got some
some points there, man.
Yeah. But that's again Nick. That's the
problem with Nick. Nick, sometimes his
mouth runs ahead of his brain and he
spits out things that later he has to
then temper down cuz he just came out
also grieving what happened with Charlie
Kirk.
Yeah. Anyway, let me now show you this
right here.
Yeah. So, remember you don't spit out
the baby with the bath water. When the
man makes good points, he makes good
points.
But I don't want to be political, guys.
My platform is not politics. I'll only
speak about Israel and Zionism as it
relates to scriptures, to the Lord Jesus
Christ, and the church. There are
experts who specialize in those areas. I
learned from them. I will stay in my own
lane. Watch here what she's saying. She
brings the receipts.
>> Okay. Can you answer those basic
questions? That would be great. Like I
said, it's interesting. You didn't even
mention BB Netanyahu at all. You can
stand up to him. Is is and does anybody
want to jump in and say no? Yeah. The
letter Charlie wrote him in May was just
like a glowing. He just want he just was
overcome with
>> talking about him being written a letter
by
one of these Jewish billionaires
rebuking Charlie for platforming Tucker
Carlson and his anti-Zionist position
because he brought in Tucker Carson in
his last TPUSA. And guess who else he
had scheduled for his TPUSA that takes
place in December in Arizona?
He wanted to bring Marjgerie Taylor, one
of the most
clearest and loudest voices against Apac
and Zionism.
The donors were not happy with Charlie
Kirk. Let me get you the link so you can
go watch this in its entirety. Now watch
here. Listen.
>> Passion and said, "I love Israel. You
guys are amazing. You're beautiful.
You're we're going to win this thing and
you're perfect and doing nothing wrong.
Love you." Beep beep.
I just find that weird that no one wants
to address the substance of the claims
here. Whether or not um maybe maybe Bill
himself has an opinion. Um whether BB
lied by severe omission when he
mentioned his last correspondences with
Charlie cuz I feel like if Charlie said
I don't want to go to Israel, you know,
just the public here, if you're trying
to decide what's real and what's fake,
whether or not what we're telling you is
real or fake, you can take Charlie in
his own words. I mean, shout out to
Village Crazy Lady on X. She's a great
follow. She just re
>> You're going to hear it from Charlie's
own words how he's becoming more
critical of Zionism and that he's angry
because of the backlash. He even says
he's been getting a lot of threats and
backlash, not that they'll kill him, but
they will defund him.
>> Let's take Charlie in his own words.
Take a listen. I my contention here is
that some in the pro-Israel camp are so
kneejerk about calling you anti-semitic
or getting deeply offended if you say
anything.
>> Can you believe they call him
anti-semitic? This guy.
>> Now watch what he's going to say.
>> That doesn't align with their narrative
that it undermines their own cause. And
I have to tell you, I find it very
irritating. Um, because I do feel like
some of us have earned the right to have
some credibility on the subject of
Israel and don't want to be called those
names when we have some mild push back
on some of the overreaches, whether
it's, you know, whether they're winning
or losing the propaganda war right now.
And my contention is they've begun to
lose it. And I realize it's propaganda
coming at us from Hamas, but they their
their numbers have turned here in
America. They've turned, not so much
with Republicans, a little bit with
Republicans, but
>> Yep. the world is turning against
Netanyahu's regime. In fact, I just
watched the clip. Did you know the
United Nations has now come out and
officially stated that Israel is
engaging a genocide? Did you know they
just came out in a report? They now are
officially calling it a genocide. what
they're doing in Palestine, United
Nations. Do you know that, guys? Whether
you agree with it or not, I'm just
letting you know the world is not scared
of MSAD or Zionists and Israel.
CNN, not CNN, you the United Nations UN
came up with a report saying they are
now engaged in genocide. Yeah, guys. You
guys, you because you're too much into
spiritual EFC. Destro the right Muslim
metaphysician.
Buddy, pay attention what's happening
around you in the world. As events
unfold, Jesus, our Lord, his return is
now closer than ever before. It's more
eminent than it was 2,000 years ago.
Right? They're calling it a genocide. UN
the world is taking notice. But now
they're going to play the victim.
Remember narcissism. Poor Louis us.
We're the victims. You're the villain.
You all hate us. And then we have to do
what we need to do to put you guys in
your places for our survival. Really?
Yeah. Okay.
>> But completely with the Democrat party
and with independence, they they have
shifted mightily from at least double
digits highs to single-digit lows now
with it with when it comes to approval.
And
>> yep. Also with respect to you and I
speculated about this at the turning
point event whether the possibility of
Jeffrey Epstein possibly being a MSAD
agent or asset or affiliated with that's
been turned around on me too to you must
be anti-semitic.
>> See that they just entertain the
possibility. Is Mstein a spy? Was he
working for Assad or some other
intelligence agency to gather dirt on
politicians in order
>> to force them to bow to Netanyahu, their
Lord and Master?
>> What the hell? That's such The
same people who say you can criticize
Israel, that's fine. We won't call you
anti-Semitic if you criticize Israel now
turn around immediately and say you're
anti-Semitic for even raising that. I
completely reject that and I raised this
as a
>> push back against my friends on that
particular strain of the aisle
>> to watch it because you don't want to
alienate people who are openly your
friends by going nuts in your crackdowns
on mild push back on anything related to
Israel.
>> I'm also I'm I'm so glad you brought
this up and I would second that.
>> You hear that? cracking down on your
friends who just bring mild push back,
who are pro- Israel, but then bringing
out dirt to threaten them. Now, look
what he's gonna say. Look, listen,
>> Megan, I think I have a bulletproof
resume showing my defense of Israel,
both on campus, on social media, to to
great, you know, let's just say mockery
and scorn at times where I because I
believe it, right? I I believe in the
scriptural land rights given to Israel.
I believe in fulfillment of prophecy.
>> That's why you suck as an exedute. I
don't mean to disrespect. His theology
is now perfected. He's with the Lord
Jesus Christ. But this is the poison of
dispensationalism, evangelicalism,
right? And the influence of Scoffield,
right? This kind of theology. But now
listen, look, he's going to come out and
say it. He was being threatened. And
>> again, I'm not a theologian, but I'm a
Christian. My life was changed in
Israel. This
>> I'm not a theologian.
my life would change in Israel. Why? Why
would your life be changed in Israel?
Why wouldn't your life change wherever
you're at? Because our Lord Jesus
addressed this. And I'm going to show
you where our Lord said, "Neither in
Jerusalem, nor on this mountain will you
worship God, but you must worship him in
spirit and truth. So why do I need my
life to be changed in Israel? My life
should be changed wherever it is. My
life should be changed in the Vatican.
Why don't I go to the Vatican City and
see an ancient church where two holy
apostles were martyed? martyed there.
Paul and Peter, right? Not only that,
but even St. Ignatius, another holy,
blessed martyr, a disciple of martyed
there. All these Christians who were
martyed there and the church is still
there. Why don't you go there and have
your life changed? Why Israel? Let me
show you what the Bible says about
Israel. The Bible, right? The one who
said he's not a theologian.
Watch here. Let me just make his point.
>> Spiritual energy is so amazing there. I
I want them to win. I've said that
repeatedly.
And however, Megan, you're hitting on
something very potent and important.
Now, let me first say I don't want to
judge an entire group because there's
been many people in the periseral world
that have been very sweet, very kind,
very nuanced, very Charlie, you know,
you're with us. You don't have to agree
all the time. However, however,
>> and I and I will say this, the behavior
by a lot, both privately and publicly
are pushing people like you and me away.
Did you hear it? This is recent, huh?
A lot of these Israeli Zionists, a lot,
not few, are now pushing us away. In
other words, getting us disgusted with
their bullying tactics, trying to find
some dirt on you to use against you, to
frame you to be their slaves. This
Charlie Kirk, guys,
not like we're going to be pro- Hamas,
not like we're going to, but we're like,
honestly, the way you are treating me is
so repulsive. I have text messages,
Megan, calling me an anti-semite. it.
When's the last time Netanyahu or any of
these Israelis mentioned
this from Charlie Kirk? When Netanyahu
came out and tweeted and oh yes, you
know, he was a great friend of Israel
and all that. Did you mention the
bullying and the intimidation that
Charlie Kirk underwent by folks like you
threatening to defund him? Because his
major donors, the billionaires, were all
Zionists.
No, you didn't, did you? No.
>> I am learning biblical Hebrew and
writing a book on the Shabbat. I honor
the Shabbat, literally the Jewish
Sabbath. I visit Israel and fight for
it. And there's
>> because your theology sucked. I'm sorry,
Char, but you're perfected now with the
Lord Jesus Christ. Shabbat,
the Lord was waking them up. And you
know, Catholics,
see what a good Catholic can do and what
a good praying Catholic woman, a pious
Catholic woman can do. She was praying
for her husband and he was opening up.
He was going to mass. She even says it
uh Candace in this session which I will
play clips sometime this week God
willing. He was praying the rosary.
That's why he even said that the holy
mother the blessed theotocos is a
beautiful example for women.
He was changing
because of the prayers of a pious godly
Catholic woman. So don't underestimate
the power of your prayers women. The
more godly you are, the more humble you
are, the more
submissive you are to the Lord Jesus
Christ, the more you seek to honor
Christ by the way you speak, conduct
yourself, the more powerful your
prayers. She was changing her husband.
Yep. Eventually you guys will come
around to see why I do what I do.
>> Another article out in the Times of
Israel today. I could read it on air.
What am I doing? I'm sorry. Like let's
just take a step back here.
>> Okay, there you go.
>> Tell you right now,
>> I'll bring you more next week. I'll
title it Charlie Kirk. But this is the
fact Charlie Kirk was waking up because
of his pious Catholic wife, a prayer
praying woman, a godly woman. Even
there's a photo of her. Photo of her if
you notice as she's going, she puts him
down and she's she has I believe a
rosary in her hand.
She has a rosary in her hand, cross in
her hand. She prayed for her husband to
come to his senses and he was coming to
his senses slowly but surely. In this
interview, I'm going to give you the
link. Go listen. Candace Owen starts by
saying she was texting Charlie because
they were best of friends. They were
best of friends. And Charlie was telling
her he prays the rosary and he's
attending the Eucharist, right? He
couldn't take it yet, but he was going.
And she says, "You're too smart to
remain a Protestant."
Yep. That's his words. Charlie Kirk, "If
the Lord had pleased to exp extend his
earthly life, he would have eventually
left evangelicalism and change his
stance on Zionism like I did." Don't
forget I started as a diehard Christian
Zionist because that's the only theology
I was taught.